so she
so she was my professor back in grad
school
and it was actually a really small class
only five of us the mathematics of
economics
and i didn't realize this at the time
but she was one of the key authors of
the kyoto protocol
and she was also a author on a
on a paper that won the nobel prize
so when i asked her to speak here i
emailed her she replied
within an hour and i was super excited
that we were going to have a uh
uh the kyoto protocol offer and one of
the authors of a nobel prize winning
paper here
she also sent us her fun fact which is
actually something i didn't know
about her at the time either i knew half
of it but not both of it
she never went to college
but then she got a phd in math
and then she got a second phd in
economics
and i have friends who have two phds
and i have friends who have a phd
without going to college
this is the first time i've seen an
intersection of no college and two phds
so i figure i'm having no college two
phds
and being on a nobel prize winning paper
we can give a uh we can give a video
talk here
thank you very much for being here today
and particularly thank you of course for
the heroes of the
medical profession that are taking care
of everybody
and in this horrific
pandemic situation that we're going
through i want to
thank to all of you not just for being
here but also for being part of the
solution
and not part of the problem
my name is graciela chichininsky and i
am the co-founder
and the ceo of global thermostat that's
a company that started in 2010
and we have a technology that can remove
co2 from the atmosphere
and transform it into bio fertilizers
in foods and beverages building
materials
synthetic fuels sea water desalination
and enhancer recovery in fact
direct air capture which is changing the
way
energy is produced the world over and
we're doing this
with extraordinary partners
that include the coca-cola company
exxonmobil
[Music]
early kid include
aqua the biggest desalination firm
in the world and saudi aramco
and more recently ame and
siemens the large engineering firm
for the production of synthetic fuels
that essentially are like gasoline
without producing
emissions in the year 2019
global thermostat was chosen among top
10 breakthrough technologies in the
world
by mit technology review curated
by bill gates so direct air capture
and global thermostat technology removes
co2 from the atmosphere
and it stabilizes it it embodies it
into projects that stabilizes co2 on
earth
so at the end of the process you end up
with less co2 in the atmosphere
and more on earth and it's accepted
by national academy of sciences and the
ipcc
that direct air capture can indeed
remove co2
is feasible technologically can remove
it from the atmosphere
as is needed now according to the united
nations it's not sufficient to limit it
anymore it has to be removed
but it can do so at low enough costs
that when you sell it
to what mckinsey says is projected to be
a trillion dollar market
you make money out of this so you
improve the economy you create jobs and
you clean the atmosphere
all at once that is the purpose of
global thermostat um
first let me tell you where this is
originated this whole thing started
20 years ago actually 23
when the nations of the world 160 of
them
voted for the killed abroad of gold
and the u.s was one of the voters
and the qt protocol was a way to prevent
catastrophic climate change in 1997
i wrote into the kyodo protocol i
designed and growed
the current market of the kyoto protocol
that works by putting limits on
emissions and allowing
those that go above the limit to
compensate those that
are below the limit just before this
horrific pandemic
started in december of 2019
physics today published an article
about the fact that the carbon market
is considered to be by economist
in terms of the price of carbon
as the necessary solution to climate
change and in fact
that carbon market that we created then
the first one
in the world the european union emission
trading system
succeeded in its purpose
so that as of now 23 years later
and become after becoming international
law in 2005
it has decreased the
emissions of 50 nations in the european
union
um those emissions are now 20
lower as they were when we started
in 2005. that means
the current market succeeded but it
means more
it means that
that amount that decrease in emissions
of these 50 nations of the european
union
if extended to all the countries that
signed the protocol then
particularly the united states
uh would have resolved climate change
that's what it means so it means that
we already had a solution over 20 years
ago
it was not implemented and i want to
talk about
why
fully but it was sufficiently
implemented that 25
of human kind is now governed
by carbon markets which are the
descendants
of the current market that i wrote in
the kyodo protocol
in 1997 and became international law
in 2005. if
if we have decreased the entire
emissions of the world
by 20 below the level of the
2005 emissions the situation now will be
essentially
resolved and we would know how to go
forward
but instead of that there was
a lot of concern about the impact that
limiting emissions
would have on the economy those concerns
were particularly in the united states
because the u.s was the largest emitter
of co2 at that point
and because of that a law
emerged in the united states the bird
seagull
law which passed in 1997
unanimously in the congress
saying that the united states would not
accept
any limitations on emissions that hurt
the global economy or that hurt actually
the us economy
and that bird seagull law
in fact detained progress
because there was the fear that
limiting emissions as required by the
tutor protocol
would have such a negative effect in the
us economy
so the u.s signed it to the protocol but
didn't ratify it and he didn't execute
it and the u.s was the largest emitter
the european union 50 nations did
and they solved the problem but we
needed the problem to be more general
now we have carbon markets in china
carbon markets in california
carbon markets in several states of the
eastern
usa and of course carbon markets in the
european union
but there was that fear that it may
hurt the economy so i was then
the lead author of the ipcc
representing the us and i know
that if we didn't take action then
something different would have to be
done and
as part of that plan i
created global thermostat to agree
on the solution that was requested if
you wish
by the birth serial act
to show that decreasing emissions does
not hurt
the economy it can be helpful to the
economy
and indeed that's what that's the
purpose
of global thermostat is to resolve
the problem of climate change in a way
that is commercially feasible
through the production of all those
services and goods
with our partners and clients that they
mentioned before
it is actually a global transformation
because now there is a technological
solution
the technological solution has two
levels
at one level the company global
thermostat
created a breakthrough technology
that removes co2 directly from the
atmosphere and it can do so
in such a way that the kernel
that is removed is commercially valuable
and is used for those purposes
that technology which is all it also
goes by
the name of director capture directly
cleans the atmosphere directly captures
the co2 and our firm can do so
at sufficiently low cost that when you
sell it
you make profits you create economic
development
and you create very good jobs
the second technological aspect that is
very important is that out of the cured
protocol
hundreds of billions of dollars traded
were used
to be unsent to developing nations
including china
particularly china for clean technology
projects and china used
their allocation for the scaling up of
photovoltaic technology
and that means that right now
thanks to the chinese effort and to the
funding
for that effort that was created by
the carbon market in 2005
when it became low we now
can be sure that the
per kilowatt hour electricity produced
by solar energy is lower cost
than the electricity that is produced by
gold
and this is important because everybody
agrees
that right now the world economy in the
next
20 years is going to double this
consumption of energy
so the solution here has two
technological parts
one is a solar revolution the
photovoltaic revolution
where you can produce solar
energy much cheaper than you can do
produ that you can produce it by using
coal and fossil fuels the second part
will have a thermostat technology that
can remove co2 directly from
the atmosphere so
the initial solution that succeeded
because he took down by 20
the emissions of co2 from the original
level
as of now amazing that solution
was only partial because only the
european union adopted it so far
but the i mean that solution now
was prevented globally
by the vision that limiting emissions
would hurt the economy
and now the new technology shows the
opposite it can be done in a
commercially feasible way
it can be done while making money while
growing the economy
and growing jobs so
that's in a way the second
time that will resolve climate change
the first time it was with the carbon
market that all economists agree
a price of carbon is needed to resolve
climate change
and that was the price of carbon and he
could do it
the second time is to show and you can
go through that solution
in a way that helps the economy in a way
that produces
jobs in a way that leads to clean
development
the clean materials clean energy
helped by the fact that the funding from
the kyoto protocol the billions the
hundreds of billion
that went to developing countries was
used to scale up the photovoltaic
photovoltaic technology leading to
very inexpensive solar energy today that
undercuts
fossil fuels the production of
electricity
this is a
successful story but is not finished
we know what we have to do we are doing
it
and we have fantastic extraordinary i
should say
technology partners and clients that i
already mentioned
in that process this is we know we have
to do that
but i wanted to say finally that
even the pope as well as many other
thinkers and other religious leaders
perceive that the
oil and gas industry plays an important
role here
and the proposal here is to work
with our technology partners with
um two folk heroes
first the creator of earthix
why we are here today tumble grow
thank you so much he has a vision
of a consortium of oil and gas companies
perhaps sitting here in texas
that can achieve the transformation
perhaps using our technology but it can
be done
and they can become part of the solution
very important
that is supported by
experts by our company for sure
and our partners and clients but also by
experts
like ted roosevelt at barclays bank
all of us have the same vision we think
that the oil and gas company can
transform itself
to part of the solution we did it once
over 20 new plus years ago
and we can do it again we're going to
reverse
climate change and overcome catastrophic
uh problem that is facing humankind
we need to do it there is no other
choice because if we don't do it we
won't be here to tell the story
so let's do it for the second time
thank you all right everybody i hope you
enjoyed
that talk uh it's very fascinating to
hear about the carbon markets and the
affected head and the
the ongoing effect of the photovoltaic
market
um so i hope everyone enjoyed that talk
got a lot out of that i wish uh doctor
trimski could have been here
uh but hopefully that video gave you all
the information she
wanted to present to you um so i enjoyed
that but also i'm a bit biased
so all right so thank you graciela
and now we have reached